player unknowns battlegrounds has taken
PC gaming by storm it's even pushed many
of us to upgrade or build our own gaming
PC but what specs should you have and
what kind of graphics settings and frame
rates should you expect
here's a quick graphics settings guide
with some performance tips before we
move on make sure you're subscribed to
GameSpot to keep up with game tech where
we break down the tech that drives the
games we love player unknowns
battlegrounds or pub G sets a pretty low
bar to clear by today's standards in
terms of minimum specs while it uses
Unreal Engine 4 it only requires an
Intel Core i3 4340 or the old AMD FX
6300 for a CPU and for the GPU either
gtx 660 or radeon HD 7850 both of which
have 2 gigabytes of video ram of course
you'd want more juice than that so as we
did with our video on the destiny 2 pc
betas graphics and performance we tested
out what we could get out of an older
mid-range system we have an Intel Core
i5 35 70 K and MSI GTX 970 and 8
gigabytes of RAM some fairly modest
specs now keep in mind that pub G is
still an early access title and updates
patches and drivers will continually
change performance across different
systems and even add new graphical
effects alright let's take a look at the
graphics settings we're given some
straightforward options but pub G has
garnered plenty of PC newcomers and some
may be new to these terms and there are
some important distinctions to be made
since these settings can significantly
affect how the game is played first off
we're gone with a standard resolution of
1080p throughout this video
anti-aliasing smooths out jagged edges
around objects turning this up will
clean up the overall image but you will
take a sizable hit and framerate
visually there isn't much of a
difference between high and ultra
shadows determines the fidelity of
shadows no brainer but it is important
that you have it set to at least medium
low and very low will not render player
shadows and being able to see a player
shadow is key to tracking opponents
indoors and anticipating enemy movement
it can make the difference between death
and survival also note that high and
very high will tax your system heavily
foliage changes the detail of brush and
grass but it does not affect the amount
that shows up in game it also doesn't
affect the distance at which grass pops
up so you won't really gain an advantage
by turning it down
the
this should be maxed out to make sure
you can see as much as possible off in
the distance it's key if you're using
high-powered scopes or trying to watch
activity from a high vantage point
post-processing encompasses effects like
ambient occlusion and dynamic lighting
low will give you ambient occlusion
which is a notable visual improvement I
will add a sort of depth of field and
very high will add dynamic lighting
effects like bloom and godrays effects
determines the number of particle used
when rendering visual effects like
gunfire and explosions the more the
better but your system will take a
performance hit when fire and explosions
fill up the screen texture improves the
detail of surfaces simple enough but
we'd suggest that least using medium
since low is a very noticeable downgrade
screen scale is super sampling if it's
set above 100 the game will render a
higher res image and downscale to fit
your display while it makes the game
look better I'd avoid using it in this
case motion blur is up to your
preference and you'll want to turn vsync
off now with our modest system and
preferred settings you're probably
wondering what kind of frame rates we
got through an entire match the frame
rate stayed between the high 50s to the
high 70s it seems that with our system
and settings we hit a sweet spot between
graphical quality and performance during
an airstrike barrage our frame rate
dipped to the low 40s with effects set
to high bringing it down to medium
helped us stay in the high 40s the
60-second warm-up before a match starts
is a good indication of a worst case
scenario when it comes to performance so
if your system can handle that with a
playable frame rate around 40 FPS you
should be able to enjoy this game
smoothly if you watched our video on the
cheap gaming PC we built we tested it in
pub G with a quad-core AMD rising 3 CPU
and a gtx 1050 at 1080p with medium
settings you roughly got high 30s to low
50s higher end systems equipped with
either the RX vega cards or a gtx 1070
and up you'd still want to take into
consideration how shadows and
anti-aliasing impact your frame rate
especially if you have a high refresh
rate monitor or want to do 4k again pub
G is still in early access and will go
through changes in optimizations there's
still occasional random hitches and
stutters and quirks - how textures load
and how effects are rendered Pub G is in
the best looking game but it is a bit
graphically demanding and can have some
hiccups with optimization but there's a
reason it's sold millions of copies
because it's fun as hell and the first
step to getting the most out of the game
is to make sure your system and the game
aren't harmony I hope you found this
helpful
and learn something about graphics
quality settings in player unknowns
battlegrounds or at least got some
context as to how the game runs if you
want more in-depth explanations of these
graphic settings check out our series of
explainers give this video a like and
subscribe to GameSpot for more content
like this and check out our other game
tech features while you're at it thanks
for watching and we'll see you next time